en el sur de nueva delhi de gestual
sandú un indio de 30 años se prepara
para una fiesta
como el resto de la comunidad lgtb
saborea la libertad que adquirido hace
cuatro años tras la despenalización de
la homosexualidad sin miedo a expresar
su identidad en público
salí del clóset hace 14 años tenía que
verme como un hombre o hablar como un
hombre actuar como caminar como un
hombre
pero ahora puedo hacer lo que quiera ir
donde quiera
y si la gente no lo acepta es problema
de ellos
en septiembre de 2018 el tribunal
supremo de india derogó el artículo 377
del código penal una ley que se
remontaba al imperio británico y
criminalizaba las relaciones entre
personas del mismo sexo la policía podía
utilizarla para detenerlos en nueva
delhi como en otras grandes ciudades del
país se han multiplicado los lugares lgp
y más friendly donde la gente puede
salir de fiesta como en cualquier otro
lugar sin preocuparse ni esconderse
antes podías ir a un lugar así y
sentirte feliz pero tan pronto como
salía sabías que entrabas en un mundo
que no te entendía dónde no estabas
protegido
ahora no tengo miedo no tengo miedo de
que me rechacen por mi sexualidad
puedo estar orgulloso aquí adentro y
afuera
la visibilidad de la comunidad que no se
limita a la vida nocturna
al día siguiente de heyward fue un
centro comercial de la capital india
durante un fin de semana en el mercado
con diseñadores lgtb
hay alguna promoción 10 de descuento
para ti no es mucho
si no se hubiera derogado el artículo
377 probablemente nunca habría ocurrido
un evento de este tipo en un lugar tan
cotidiano
el joven de 30 años comparte el evento
con sus 112 mil seguidores de instagram
las redes sociales le están ayudando a
la generación
más joven a tener más visibilidad
el hecho de que tengamos plataformas
como esta para reunirnos a la vista de
todo el mundo también significa que hay
que tenerlos en cuenta
nadie podrá volver a silenciar los
una visibilidad que se está haciendo
parte de la vida cotidiana de los indios
el reto de xurés ramdas elegido mister
gay india en 2019 es la inclusión en el
trabajo y si como individuo uno se
levanta y dice esto no está bien
entonces esa persona se sentirá segura
como actuar ante alguien que es víctima
de discriminación cómo reaccionar cuando
alguien sale del closet
esto es lo que enseña cada mes en esta
empresa del silicón valley' indio en
bangalore para luchar contra los
estereotipos
esto ayuda a mucha gente ofrecemos un
espacio seguro especialmente para las
personas que no han salido del closet o
que aún no están seguras de su
sexualidad
hay una concienciación entre los
dirigentes y la gente así que este tipo
de programa es realmente necesario se lo
recomiendo a todas las empresas
este tipo de iniciativas ayudan a romper
los tabúes pero romper las
representaciones culturales es una lucha
constante
un ir es director hace 17 años fue uno
de los primeros en hablar de la
homosexualidad en el cine esta noche se
encuentra en una librería para el
lanzamiento de su autobiografía
estamos constantemente invadidos por
esta heteronormatividad abrumadora y
todo lo que conlleva la representación
heterosexual
son pocos los artistas que son
abiertamente homosexuales como él
especialmente en one y but a pesar de
algunos avances aún queda mucho camino
por recorrer
la mayoría de las veces la
representación que se hace de las
personas lgtb de más proviene de un
punto de vista muy heteronormativo sobre
cómo quieren vernos como nos aceptan
pero no sobre cómo vivimos realmente
nuestras vidas
es una visión muy patriarcal y
conservadora de la sociedad que también
afecta a las lesbianas indias muchas no
pueden vivir su homosexualidad
abiertamente y están sometidas a fuertes
presiones sociales especialmente la de
casarse con un hombre
marcia de 23 años huyó de la casa de su
familia hace dos años era la única
manera de escapar al mar con un
desconocido escogido por sus padres
pensando en suicidio me pregunte si lo
mejor no sería saltar al metro
encontró refugio en una asociación que
ayuda a lesbianas y transexuales
desde entonces parchea salió del closet
pero su padre sigue gastando miles de
rupias con sacerdotes hindúes para
conseguirle un marido
dice mi nombre el de mis padres y el de
mi comunidad y luego hace oraciones para
que me casé pronto
hoy en día les parecería inaceptable que
quisiera casarme con una mujer marek tu
abdomen
[Música]
si la constitución me lo permitiera
entonces podría decirles miren la ley lo
permite tengo derecho no estoy haciendo
nada malo
pero no es el caso
tras una primera victoria hace cuatro
años la comunidad lgtb de cubas espera
obtener más derechos el matrimonio para
las parejas del mismo sexo es el
siguiente paso en una larga lucha